(audience applauding)
Hey, Drew, what's going on?
Hi Michael, how are you?
I'm pretty good, no complaints.
You know, been a crazy year,
but I'm hanging in there.
I know, I know, it really has.
And you just bring so much joy to everyone's life,
so thank you for being out there
and doing what you do.
You know, like you I love what I do
so it makes it easy.
You just be yourself, enjoy your life,
and everything else kind of just falls into place, I think.
And a lot of this segment
really means a lot to me personally
because when the pandemic started
I started growing my first herb garden.
And I've always been intimidated by it.
I never thought I could do it.
And I started by growing herbs in the kitchen.
And then what it built into was
I started with garden boxes,
and I eventually grew a big garden.
Teach us how to do this.
I now know it's possible.
I have now done it and accomplished it.
And it is the most romantic way
to live and cook so this
really means a lot to me, this segment.
Take us through it.
All right, so I am a huge gardener,
have been for a long time.
Something about being in the dirt
just makes me incredibly happy,
and it's so rewarding.
So at the end of the season,
because I live in places that are cold,
it's hard to do a garden outside.
You can do a hoop garden
and things of that nature,
but it's easier to move it inside.
So I'm gonna show you how to make a quick
hydroponic style herb garden inside.
Hydroponic.
So the first thing you need is,
hydroponic, fancy. (laughing)
It's like the 90's.
Yeah.
You need a tinted jar.
So you could either get a tinted jar
or you could paint a ball,
I took a clear ball jar and painted it,
either one is fine.
Oh, that's nice.
And the reason that you do this
is you don't want,
if it's clear it's gonna get a lot of algae inside.
So this is just a way to keep the water from getting funky.
Then I just take a couple stones
and I put them in the bottom of my jar.
Now, Drew, in addition to the jar
I have a little,
you could buy these at the hardware store,
the strainers that you put in your shower or whatever.
Or your sink.
Yeah, or your sink.
They're like a buck.
And what we did is I just cut a hole,
we already cut yours for you.
You cut a hole in the bottom of it.
You could do it with just wire cutters.
But you cut the hole in the bottom.
And now you're gonna take your herbs.
And I have thyme here.
And I actually pulled the thyme out of my garden outside.
And we just shook out all the additional dirt
and rinsed it.
And now you're gonna take the roots
and put them through that little hole in your basket.
Then you put that in your,
right on top of your jar,
your mason jar.
I have water here.
I have a little bit of organic plant feed
that you should add every couple weeks.
So just follow whatever the directions are
on your plant feed.
You put the water in,
and then I like to just take
some little pebbles
and put them around the top.
Just to kind of stablizie
Weight it down.
Yeah.
Like so.
And that's it.
Do you recommend a little organic enhancement like--
Yeah, you could take a little bit of plant food,
organic plant food.
And it's usually like a half a teaspoon
per two cups of water
or something like that,
but it'll have the directions right on there.
And I read that every two weeks or so.
This is beautiful.
And then if you look behind me,
I have, we have all of our herbs growing in our window here.
And I'm in a southern window
so I get about six hours of light a day,
which is great.
If you don't have a southern window
you could do the same exact thing
with a grow light.
Perfect.
There you go.
Man, that is, I'm moving into your studio, Drew,
that's fantastic.
You like it, Michael Simon?
If you like it I--
It's so good.
Thank you.
I love design.
Oh my God.
That is my space.
It looks fantastic.
Now the best part about this,
Drew, is you grow these inside.
And I'm gonna show you now
how to make a little herb pea stew
with a soup that's gonna go on top.
So you could actually,
not only grow these and they look beautiful,
but I wanna show you how
to make a little lunch with them too.
(upbeat music)